michael walker to the mound
and he's trying to turn his
trend around a little bit for michael
you know you're thinking about fastball
command we talked about it in the
pre-game show fastball command sharp
cutter and then a good changeup if you
get that combination from waka then
you've got a chance to get a really good
start tim anderson ease it first and
there's luis robert the 2-2 pitch again
this is a fastball and it's ripped to
right field by robert that's a way to
provide energy early in the ball game
here comes tim around third and luis
robert has an early sox rbi and a one
nothing lead in the first this is so
good this ball is tilt i mean absolutely
killed to right um nice double by louise
he gets a fastball in the outer third
right here and just does not miss it i
mean he is so square
at foot down right there and when i say
that he's just there's no leak on his
front hip he stays right on this ball
and just drills it down the right field
line i mean everything that i've seen
from him since he's come back from the
il has been really impressive i mean
just very
he's showing an advanced approach signal
to the double by anderson and robert
here's jose mourinho
and cut the minutes he strikes out abreu
and he got him on the change-up well
he's got a good one michael walker has a
very good change up because he's able to
get laid action with it he throws that
three finger prong turns it over a
little bit and
the arm action is excellent so with one
out a runner at second a run home hello
jimenez is the hitter 3-2
and a swing and a miss he strikes him
out how about that state with the
off-speed stop there yeah
and that was a hard change up for
walking the same one that he was able to
get afraid with there it is turn it over
great arm action the best of the bunch
and he does get jimenez to fire on it
just a little bit too soon
one two
fly ball center field kirmar's gonna
have to go back a few steps but he's
there
at the end of one half inning it's the
white sox one and the razor coming up
here at the top after this you've got
lucas giolito here obviously he's been
doing very good the last seven times out
uh six out of the last seven he has let
uh two or a few fewer runners uh score
and so he's coming in feeling good
obviously he's his mix his fourth seam
fastball change up slider and a
curveball right but we all know that
forcing fastball and change up for his
bread and butter granted loud and
there's a slider right he's he's doing a
much better job so with two outs of the
bases empty here's nelson
3-2 fastball sends him away lucas
bookends strikeouts
stevie zavala the catcher is going to be
up here ground ball that's going to go
through the hole into left meadows will
come up to meet it the throw will come
to the plate and he is
out at the plate meadows charged that
ball in left and got the throw away to
the plate in fact you know it's
interesting as that ball's coming into
his glove he was straddling the play
right here straddle straddle straddle
now you catch it you're moving your feet
drop the tag he's out that's it well i
think they've made a decision and he is
out yup two outs two men on go to the
count and he got a swing and a miss he
strikes him out and michael walker able
to wiggle off the hook as he strikes out
tim anderson so two outs g-man 246 this
year eight homer's 37 knocked in
now joyce sends one deep to center field
robert will go back he's gonna look up
that baby's gone
home run for g-man george
joy on the first pitch hits number nine
and this game is tied at one well here
it is fastball and it catches too much
play that's the thing both of these
pitchers here tonight be ready to hit
early on g-man choi gets that first
pitch out of here that's the sixth home
run that g alito has given up on the
first pitch of an at-bat and one ball
and two strikes
he elicits the most swings and misses in
the game with a one-two swing and a miss
he struck him out another good slider by
uh giolito right there showing that he
can really throw this to righties and
lefties really good strike the ball the
raisin white sox are tied at one here's
mike zanino
it goes to hernandez and cesar
throws out zadino speed is not his
friend and he knows that he'll tell you
that two outpaces empty and that'll
leave it for brandon loud
oh good change you said it second time
through infield in run with third one
out for jose abreu 0-1 curveball to
third and on contact safe
tim slid by the tag from zanino
diaz the feed and tim says no no no
we're taking the lead 2-1 this is such a
great slide by ta man one and one to
moncada from michael walka who's gone
four and two thirds sox had the lead and
johan slices this ball to center kier
meyer has no play bring him home four
one
that was a bomb
ground ball short stop and it comes up
and hits franco in the face
vaughn is aboard on what turns out to be
a really bad hop bait's head he tried to
play that as a preset backhand and watch
the ball it's just going to hit his
glove
and right straight up it's like when you
you you miss a bunt he just missed the
ball off the heel of the glove straight
up off the side of the face they're
gonna charge franco with an error on
that and there's out number one here in
the fifth and well mark go
fly ball left center field that's gonna
drop and we'll get by
jimenez
we're gonna watch margot run around
second on his way to third and he is in
there easily well ahead of the throw
third triple of the year from argo well
and that's big because you get that
runner to third with less than two
here's kevin kiermeier the man in third
with one out in the home half of the
inning
fly ball center field
robert in not overly deep he'll make the
catch
margot can fly and he is safe at the
plate boy he came in had to get around
the
leg of zavala and the rays pick up their
second run of the game making it four to
two andrew vaughn two on two out
by popper down the right side joy toward
the bullpen got it nice running grab
g-man choi tracks it down to retire the
side but he went all the way down near
the home plate area in the bullpens and
caught it on the side warning track
really well done to end the inning looks
like kermeyer to pull on the infield
three and one
and he does hernandez flags it down he
was right where the ball got hit with a
step for out number one great reaction
right here by hernandez this ball has
really hit hard this is a great job by
hernandez to snag this bronco now facing
the left two outs first and third 2-0
franco a chop toward the middle that's
caught by anderson the throne at second
is wide
everybody's safe the rays get a run that
will be a base hit for franco
and now it's a one-run ball game below
the bases
so it will be an intentional walk
with austin meadows due up
and
up the middle
where rosa has scored here comes bronco
braves lead 5-4
did we not say this is awesome anderson
big 3-2 here from shogua anderson drives
it into left-center field kier meyers
back it's gone
10 ties the ball game on a 3-2 pitch
leading off the ninth to the bottom of
the night yeah we got a new pitcher uh
garrett crochet is on the mound high
kicking lefty coming out of the pin
throwing gas he leads off with a walk
and now margot will back and an 0-2
is strike three a slider to the outside
third and one gone really good pitch by
crochet right here that's troy over
there owen two on kiermeier
slider in the zone pumped to center and
robert's got it squared for out number
two zunino at the plate with substantial
power
slider tied him up in strike three
garrett crochet with a brilliant job to
pitch over the walk tim anderson's
having a big night catrice on three and
two collins at second
tim grounds a slider through the
right-hand side
collins waved around third here comes
zach throw to the plate is offline tim's
into second base and seven did it again
it's six five socks i mean he's doing it
all timid third one gone
jose toward third yandy diaz had to back
up on it and this is caught at first but
the sox get a run and the socks are up
7-5 g-man choi cruz at third two down
he got him in the socks win oh he
fashioned him a change-up
and tim anderson in the sox put up seven
with two in the 11th and wins 7-5